This is wired auto complete answer.
And why can't we do this? We had that problem.
Hey, I'm Tim Heidecker and I'm John C. Riley.
Is the wired autocomplete interview who? John C. Riley,
who is John C. Ryan.
Starting off with an easy question. I am John C. Riley.
This is LSD. Next question.
Who's saying John C. Riley E in Wockhardt.
Who sang? I mean like who sang for me? How dare you ask me that question?
I sang all of my sing own singing in that movie.
And in every movie I've ever appeared in a singing has always been me.
Although the birds had a great song called John Riley and they sang that song.
That's must've been what they were the old folk song called John Riley.
I recommend it.
Is John C. Riley in guardians of the galaxy.
Let's see, I play a corpsman day.
Who is part of the Nova Corps, the kind of intergalactic police force.
There's no question marks in any of these.
Very hard to say these correctly does.
John says John C. Riley.
Very few people.
I look a lot like my brothers and sisters, that's weird. And my father,
my late father, that was one of the things coming up as an actor.
Like I was looking for an example. I like,
how could I be an actor who is like me? And there was no,
there was nobody like me, which I thought was a, was a problem.
But then someone explained to me that's good because then you'll be unique.
But the only thing I could ever relate to as a kid was like,
kind of Micky Dolenz kind of Elliot Gould.
Like they had curly hair, like that was about it.
And all the hardware Hardy, you think,
I look like all you did when you did all that, when you did the movie, was that.
It was makeup. Yeah. Although the first, my first meeting with that director,
I said, what are you thinking about this for? I just lost a bunch of weight.
What are you thinking about for this thing? He's like, well,
would you want to wear a suit? And I was like, yeah,
I'm not getting 120 pounds now. It's your turn to be on the hot seat, Tim.
We've got dark to close my eyes. No is Tim.
Heidecker really glued them on tight. Real. I think I can answer this question.
He's very real.
I'm the real deal, but I do play fake characters named Tim. Hi Decker.
So there's confusion there. Good point. And I,
I do need to think about changing my name. I'm going to legally change my name.
I've decided Tim Jones.
Is Tim. Heidecker funny. I personally think Tim is one of the funnest.
Oh yes. Sorry.
People don't think I'm funny and that's fine because there's a lot of people I
don't think are funny and it's relative. I make myself laugh. I probably,
uh, at myself more than other people do, but you seem to think I'm funny.
And I have funny friends.
Funny, but looks aren't. Everything is Tim Heidecker really.
Right. Running.
For district. Attorney.
Character is named Tim Heidecker.
He ran for district attorney and lost a couple of years ago.
Against Rosati. The rat, the rat Vincent Rosati is Tim Honaker.
Married. Sorry.
Interesting. I just had lunch with Tim and his wife. Sorry ladies. It's Tim. Hi,
Decker. Me married to.
Nice. Married to Eric. We obviously Jan,
Skyler and Wayne Schuyler are married.
The only married news team in the Tri-County area.
Eric's probably the man I've kissed the most. We are in a way,
married in a sort of legal sense. You know, we, the, your company,
the company exists. It's a legal partnership. Oh,
here comes. Rob Riley was round two.
Man. There's a full box of questions, folks, if you're bored now, just,
this is a lot more coming in. Hear a voiceover of letters that you've written.
What? Dear mother, the winter is coming strong.
I'm still doing the wired autocomplete interview. What is.
The John C. Riley GIF. GIF.
I mean, there's like.
Oh, you know, Phil Johnson tried to tell me that it's called jifs okay.
They're not shifts. Okay. They're gifts. Phil.
Just take this moment to tell Phil that probably the most famous gifts of me on
the internet are ones that are actually of someone else. Dr. Steve Brule.
I look a lot like him.
So I guess you could say that's a gift of me.
I want to say Jeff after lecturing, Phil, about how it's a gift.
Well, I use it all the time to communicate those gifts.
Jeff's Oh, okay. What is John
[inaudible] like in real life that's should be a secret.
I don't know if you need to get into that. Yeah.
I like, it's such a general question. I'm all right. You know,
I was just a human being. I have my interests, not perfect. Try to be healthy.
Try to have a lot of empathy. I'm not putting on some character right now.
This is what I'm like.
What is John C Reilly's eye color. Do you know?
Ah, I should have looked. This is an easy one. I should get this.
I was just in the bathroom and the mirror. Um, my eyes are blue.
Come on. What is John C. Reilly band? Well,
my first band was called shark fighter.
Me and my brother had a band called shark fighter.
And then I had a band called frozen spit in my twenties.
And then I had a band called stereo blues,
which is a blues band where I played the harmonica.
And now my current band is called John Riley and friends. Very easy to remember.
I also call myself John Riley and friends in the band because it's the one place
I don't have to put the, but dang,
see I'm required by sag to make my name. John C.
Reilly because there used to be another John Riley in the union.
I always thought it was Chauncey Riley. Your name was Chauncey Riley.
By secret pseudonym. Okay, Tim,
why was Tim and Eric canceled? We canceled.
Well, we said a lot of nasty things.
You weren't canceled. He walked away.
No, we, we, uh, we walked away to do a movie that was very unsuccessful.
Why is Tim and Eric funny?
Yeah. W I, you know, again, relative terms,
I don't appreciate the grammar full of controversy or Tim and Eric.
So weird. We love weirdness. We love weird new out.
We love being weird and random.
I'm working on new characters because he's real. My name is my name is John.
All right. He's weird. Cause the world is weird.
And if you react to it in an honest way, you are weird.
Why is John internet? Why is John C. Riley? An actor?
I'm an actor because I love to tell a story.
It's because people started to pay me to do it and it became my life.
I didn't really set out to be an it.
Why is John C. Reilly on Timmins?
I'm not on Tim and Eric.
I'm an executive producer on check it out with Dr. Steve Brule.
You handle a lot of the finances and just finances.
I do a lot of the scheduling and budgeting.
Why, why John C. Riley, voice actor. Why John C. Riley, a voice actor. Why not?
Uh, because, uh, it's fun to be a voice actor. You can wear whatever you want.
No one puts makeup on your face or anything weird like that.
You just go in and goof around. And then if you make a mistake,
you just do it again.
There's never any pressure when you're doing voiceover work. It's just like,
yeah, we got time.
Unique and distinctive on the eyes for us. But also on the ears.
You've got a very, you got your own.
Which I have discovered during the pandemic times I wear a full mask,
sunglasses, hat, whatever people are like, love your work.
And hear me say one thing, like, you know, I have a order of fries. I was like,
Holy. I love your work. Like wow, can Tim Heidecker cook? I can cook.
It's easy. Consume. Heidecker sing.
No, no mommy. Mom. Mama. Of course.
Yeah. Tim actually released a great record called for fear of death.
Fear of death. Continue. Heidecker act well,
tune in to moon base eight on November 8th.
And you'll see him act his off with me and Fred Armisen. Ken,
Tim Heidecker stand up. Let's see.
Come on. You can do better than that. Yeah, he can stand up. In fact,
he has a standup special coming out. That's right. What's that called? Uh,
an evening with Tim hider and eating too hot.
How,
how to contact John C. Riley?
Let me just use this opportunity to tell everyone out there.
I am not on social media in any way.
So if you see someone says John C.
Riley official or verified or whatever the hell, it ain't me, folks and Amy,
I don't have enough time to do the things I like to do in my life.
Let alone things like social media.
How tall is John C. Riley? What would possibly be in feet?
62, but I used to say six one and a half.
So it sounded like I wasn't too tall on my resume.
How old was John C. Riley in Gilbert.
Grape. Oh, Gilbert and Gilbert grapes.
How, what was my age? Let's see.
That movie was made in 1992,
I believe. And I was born in 65, 75, 85.
Uh, this is where I lose my math. I was 20, 28.
How did John Sierra? This is a good quote.
I don't think I know the answer to this. How did John C.
Reilly and will Ferrell meet?
We met through Molly. Shannon. I was friends with Molly.
I'd done a movie with her called never been kissed.
And I was in New York and I think I had brunch with Molly and she's
like, you should meet my friend. You, you guys would really get along.
You would love him will came and met us on the West side highway in Manhattan,
where we were walking to Molly's apartment. And I looked at will.
And I was like, Oh my God, she's right. I totally like this guy, like.
Soul connection. Let's see on SNL.
He's on us. I know with her at the time,
but I just didn't really know it was early days.
I almost did feel related to him in some weird way. Tim,
what is Tim Heidecker height nine. What is your Zodiac?
What is [inaudible] versus.
What does Tim Heidecker versus California? What does that mean? Oh,
well that was the trial probably when, uh,
probably the official name was the reference to another.
On cinema. Tim portrayed himself.
What are Tim Heidecker kitchen tips is one of my favorite.
Shows that Tim's ever done. Tim's kitchen tips, very sauce, heavy kitchen.
It was, you know, on Facebook a few years ago,
there was all those videos where it was just those, the ukulele playing.
And it was everyone just mixing things and making everything look so
easy. And now you do it, then there's this and there's this.
And then it's like this compounded on top of each other. And I just said, well,
why don't we do that? Just making Russian dressing,
which is just two ingredients, but then it's about five minutes of stirring.
It really is amazing. Check out Tim's kitchen tips.
What is Tim Heidegger's office hours?
Nah, 10:00 AM on Thursdays, uh,
on the YouTube channel of Tim Heidegger's YouTube channel and it's,
it's sort of my Larry King live.
Yeah, it was like Tim,
you decided to just like reach out to the fans directly and really just.
And he just started calling in early on and you would call in because you were
just sitting at home,
having breakfast and you'd call in and go on and on about your Asya bowls that
you're eating. And the joke was I would go, okay, thank you.
Yeah, color. Yeah. I want it to support you now at it. It's become this.
Huge thing. It's the number one podcast in the world.
My final thoughts on what the internet wants to know about me is like maybe the
internet should be a little more creative. Like these,
these are the things that are very easily answered. For the most part.
I would be Googling more things like, you know, how can I find meaning,
uh, how do I, how can I help my community?
How can I learn to be more empathetic and, and more, don't worry about people.
I guess. We're we, we w we're not very introduced.
Fine. You know,
one thing I would like to ask the Internet's help with whatever questions you
ask about me. Just Google my name as many times as you can,
because I'm going to hot competition with John C.
Calhoun president and John C McGinley.
Autocomplete. It's John C and then yeah.
Yeah. W Calhoun no, no, no, no. You want to John C. Riley.
So everyone just pumped my name in there as many times as you can flush
Calhoun's Calhoun was not a great president. Yeah.
He's not a president. Yeah. He was. There's no way. He was a president,
which we had the answer to reveal. Um,
so I can name all the presidents and he's not wanting to, yeah,
I'm going to guess. He was just saying.
Senator John C and look, my name comes up first.
John C.
Calhoun is vice president of the United States.
He was a heartbeat away from the president right or wrong. He was beat away.
He wasn't a Senator. All right. So folks, help me out.
Get this Calhoun bomb off my search engine.